con un alto ejecutivo en el banquillo de
los acusados en tegucigalpa la capital
de honduras inició el juicio oral contra
david castillo ex presidente de la
empresa de sa por el asesinato de la
ambientalista berta cáceres en 2016
aunque el homicidio ya conllevó condenas
a siete personas de hace tres años esta
vez es diferente porque se juzga al
presunto autor intelectual del asesinato
en juicio se comprobarán los ataques y
las agresiones sistemáticas en contra de
berta cáceres la comunidad inca y el
copinh como represalia a su labor en la
defensa y reivindicación de derechos
cuando fue asesinada a berta cáceres
luchaba contra la construcción de una
represa hidroeléctrica en territorio
indígena lenca un proyecto de la empresa
dehesa dirigida en ese momento por david
castillo la ambientalista vivía desde
hacía años bajo constantes amenazas por
su actividad política y tanto ella como
las comunidades lencas acusaban a la
empresa de estar detrás de las amenazas
y los intentos de asesinato
david castillo está en prisión desde
2018 cuando fue apresado en un
aeropuerto tratando de salir del país
está acusado de proporcionar logística y
recursos a uno de los autores materiales
del homicidio
este juicio podría resolver la incógnita
alrededor de un caso que conmocionó el
mundo pero sobre todo a américa latina
una de las regiones donde más defensores
del medio ambiente son asesinados